hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
HD tutorial and in this one I'll be
showing you guys these sexiest Firefox
add-on that I have ever seen now I do
say add-on because it's not a theme in
fact but it does it does mod your
Firefox look and I just think that this
this add-on is so worthy of a video I
mean I mean I know installing Firefox
add-ons is very simple but I just feel
like showing you this because I was
blown away when I saw this so guys of
course in order to find Firefox add-on
so I have to do is Google exactly that
so let's go to Firefox add-ons and the
first link will be add-ons Mozilla org
which again like I said in the
thunderbird video um it's pretty much
the only place that I recommend you get
add-ons and yes I will be doing a
beginner's guide to thunderbird video
since a lot of you guys seem to have
problems small problems with thunderbird
anyway let's just go right ahead and
type in all glass into the search box
and you can search all add-ons doesn't
really matter but you're gonna have to
find it it is it is under themes or
looks but if we just scroll down you'll
find it here it is all glass Firefox mod
based on Glasser and this is exactly
what you want to click on just go ahead
and click on it it's rated 5 stars 56
reviews and 13,000 weekly downloads and
more than 60,000 in total you guys are
definitely gonna want to check this out
the thing is it is an experimental
add-on and I don't really have a problem
with that it's just cool that it adds
the Vista and Windows 7 glass frame
everywhere in Firefox so the entire
thing and that is what makes it so so
good-looking so just go ahead and check
the let me install this and experimental
add-on and add to Firefox and windows so
once you've done that like I said the
steps are very rudimentary and once
you've followed them just go ahead and
go to tools and add-ons again and go to
extensions and you're going to want to
find that all-glass Firefox mod
extension not under themes and hit that
enable button and once you restart
Firefox you will witness the incredible
beauty of such an add-on and if you
don't like it let me know because I
definitely want to show you guys the
coolest themes but this is what it looks
like when it's not in a full window
again
pretty slick look you can see or down
here along the bottom
I might have to tweak this a little bit
so I can change the colors of the
weather but up here at the top that's
really a beautiful add-on and maximized
it's all black it's looking really sleek
I really couldn't ask much more from
this add-on the tab button glows when
you hover over it all these these things
at the top right here you see they kind
of glow when you when you hover over
them so it's really really clean add-on
and like I said from me it Aaron's the
title of sexiest add-on by far so if you
have a cooler add-on to show me if you
just have any tech questions you can go
ahead and PM me through youtube or just
show me show me in person you can go
ahead and make a video and send it to me
and I do answer all questions and
comments and concerns anyway thanks for
watching this h2 tutorial guys I hope
you liked it and enjoy that a pretty
awesome Firefox add-on thanks for
watching guys peace